Oh, hello my little darling.
Man... [bleep] You. You. Suck
my... [bleep]
This house ain't... [bleep]
Mrs. Whittaker.
I have been babysitting
for 20 years.
I've seen it all.
The thing is,
Forest is a unique child.
Everything is going to be fine.
I want you to have a good time
tonight, you deserve it.
Okay. Good luck.
Thank you.
Goo-ga-ga.
Hey there, Forest.
Goo-goo-ga-ga.
I want milk.
You want me
to get you your bottle, buddy?
I want milk.
Okay.
This is a baba.
I want mama's milk.
Why can't I have mama's milk?
It's a simple request.
Yeah, well,
you can't have mama's milk
right now, buddy.
How about we play?
Okay.
I want to play with my Legos.
Okay, yeah.
Buddy, let's get
your Legos then.
I want to put
the smallest Lego in my mouth,
that's what
I'm going to do.
No, you can't do that.
Why?
First you tell me
I can't have mama's milk,
now you can't have
the smallest Lego in my mouth?
What a night.
This is a bad start.
Forest, it's dangerous.
Let me get this straight,
you're in charge of me
in my house?
All right, Forest,
it's time for bed.
I guess then you're
gonna sing me a song.
What?
Mama always sings me a song
before I go to sleep.
Are you going to do that for me?
Okay, okay, yeah, yes. I will.
Hush little baby
don't say a word.
Keep singing.
Mama's going
to buy you a mocking bird.
Put my name in there.
I like it personal.
Hush baby Forest Whittaker,
don't say a word.
Goo-goo-ga-ga.
Mama's going to
buy you a mocking bird.
Good babysitter.
And if that
mockingbird don't sing.
Have a good cry.
Mama's going to
buy you a diamond ring.
Hey babe.
Hi.
I made a really big decision
without consulting you.
I went by a puppy rescue
stand on University Avenue.
I had to, I had to.
You got us a dog?
Yeah I did.
Oh, my God.
So, honey, I've got
to tell you something, okay?
These rescue dogs have had
some tough situations.
A lot of them take on
the personality of their owners.
This dog was owned
by rapper Ice-T.
All right
little buddy, come on out.
Hello my little darling.
Man... [bleep] You. You. Suck
my... [bleep]
This house ain't... [bleep]
Okay buddy, take it easy.
A little testy.
Nothing ever been
easy for me in my life.
Now hook me up with a treat.
You want a treat, buddy?
You want a treat?
Is that what you want?
Here you go. Here you go.
Yeah, that's
a tasty ass treat right there.
Now give me the whole bag.
Okay, one treat is enough.
Bitch, was I talking to you?
Give me the whole bag of treats
because I'm a treat killer
and a mother... [bleep]
Handful.
Somebody's grumpy today.
Grumpy wumpy.
I'll lay my ass
right up
on this comfortable ass sofa.
I'm going to sleep on this bitch
too as a matter of fact.
You know what mother...
And bitch, I'm going to piss...
[ bleep] here too.
No, oh, no.
[bleep] ... You man.
Raise your hand at me.
Okay. I've got
something for you little guy.
Huh? Huh?
You want to play fetch?
You like fetch?
Get that ball.
[bleep] ... You.
Both y'all
condescending mother... [bleep]
I ain't your entertainment,
bitch.
So [bleep] ...you.
Get the door.
Well, hello. Who is this?
Come on, Cocoa.
Don't worry
about these mother... [bleep]
That's my bitch, Cocoa.
Oh, I forgot to tell y'all?
She gonna be living here, too.
Wow. Okay.
You got your little friend here.
Yeah.
Well you can...
she can play here for a while.
Sure.
Puppy play date.
Yeah.
Play date?
We going to have a
[bleep] ...date.
That's what we're
going to have, Bitch.
Come here, Bitch.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, okay. He's doing that.
Are you?
Oh, no. Don't do that.
Oh.
Yeah, that's my shit too.
Oh. Oh, dear.
Get the fuck out of here.
It's about to get graphic
in this bitch.
Oh, boy.
How come you
don't do that with me?
I told you.
He does it.
I just want to
keep this area clean.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Darius Rucker.
Singing.
Hootie. Hootie.
Hootie.
Hootie. Hootie. Hootie.
Nah. Nah.
Hootie. Hootie.
Nah, nah, nah.
I'm not in Hootie and
the Blowfish any more, y'all.
Doing my own thing.
What do you mean in Hootie
because you are Hootie, man.
Come on everybody.
Hootie. Hootie.
Hootie. Hootie. Hootie. Hootie.
Nah.
Nah. Nah. All right, now. Nah.
Nah. Stop it. Stop it.
I'm not Hootie.
I'm Darius Rucker. All right?
I used to be the front man
for a band called Hootie
and the Blowfish.
All right?
But I was never Hootie.
There was never a Hootie.
If I may.
If I may ask,
where are the Blowfish at?
Right guys?
Come on everybody. Blowfish.
Blowfish. Blowfish.
Blowfish. Blowfish. Blowfish.
No, no, no.
There are no people known
as the Blowfish, y'all.
Okay? The whole band was just
called Hootie and the Blowfish.
That's it.
It was a nonsense name.
Like Hoobastank or Toad
the Wet Sprocket.
Oh.
Ohhhhh.
Singing.
Oh, oh, and what? What is it?
I see. I get it now.
I understand.
Hey, we gotta pick y'all.
We gotta choose between
Hootie or The Blowfish.
So who wants to see
the Blowfish?
Yay.
There's no Blowfish.
And who wants to see Hootie?
Mm-hmm (negative)
Hey.
That hurts my feelings, y'all.
But you said you weren't Hootie.
No. I'm not, sir.
But in the question
you just asked the audience,
I was clearly Hootie.
So you are Hootie?
I'm not, though.
Speaker 11: He is Hootie.
Yay. Hootie. Hootie.
Hootie. Hootie. Hootie.
Hootie. Hootie. Hootie. Hootie.
Nobody likes you, you girl.
Well, you're
a different color than me
and that's bad.
Oh, yeah. Well you dress like a-
Now, hold on a second.
Whoa. Mr. T.
Never make fun
of a way a man dresses.
Way a man dresses
is his business. Remember that.
Whether it's overalls,
chains or feather earrings,
however they dress
is not to be joked about.
I pity the fool that judges
another man's clothing.
I'm sorry I judged
your clothing.
It's okay.
Hey, Scout.
There's a man over there
who said he'll give us candy
if we get in his van.
I don't know if that's
a good idea, Timmy.
What are you afraid of?
Is it because you have
a stupid name like Scout?
Hey.
Whoa, Mr. T. Again.
Never make fun
of a person's name.
Your mama gave you that name
or you made it up
for business purposes.
Either way, it's personal.
I pity the fool that makes fun
of another man's name.
Mr. T.'s a cool name.
It's a cool name, Mr. T.
Hey, Scout.
Want to do some drugs?
Scout: Aren't drugs bad?
I don't know.
If you're afraid of drugs,
we can drink a bunch of alcohol.
Yeah. That sounds good.
Well, guess what?
Your hair is stupid.
Never make fun
of another person's hair.
Hey, Mr. T.
A person's hair
is the artwork
that they present
to the heavens.
It's just like I've been saying.
Hair. It isn't fair.
Beware.
People care about their hair.
H is for the home
where I lay my head
and I cry about
your mean jokes in my bed.
A is for anxiety
that fools provoke
when they lookin' at my hair
and they making jokes.
I is for I don't
like the way I feel
when you're joking
that my haircut does not appeal.
R is for the real
mean jokes you make
and the hurtful little
pot shots that you take.
And for your information,
it's not even a haircut.
It's a rare form
of male-pattern baldness.
You fools.
For real.